or Jamie and I as Labor's Shadow schools
Minister Stephen Morgan hi uh let's
start with whether you would release all
your WhatsApp messages
well they'd be pretty boring to be
honest okay but would you do it
um would you no
well I think to end encryption you know
people are talking to you privately I'm
sure there's some data protection rules
that have been broken there I mean call
me old-fashioned but I think you should
govern the country via meetings with
civil servants in the room with minutes
of meetings
um I think this is about him promoting
his book is it not a breach of trust
absolutely but I mean it's not the first
time that the government have breached
the trust of the British people is it
um so I think lessons got to be learned
and the key is right to raise with the
Prime Minister that we need to bring
forward the code inquiry so lessons
could be learned for the future I'm not
sure about promotion in this book I
think it's still 4 000 in the first two
weeks but you know that's perhaps a
conversation for when Mr Hancock as as
and when he wants to come on the show
what about though the criticism and some
of the content we'll go through the
criticism of teachers who don't want to
work
the teaching profession is a crisis
Point we've got a real issue around
Recruitment and Retention of our
teachers uh the number of teachers that
are leaving the profession is now higher
than those that are joining profession
vacancies are up 246
I think the stuff that we've seen in
these WhatsApp messages is a real kick
in the teeth for teachers across our
country
um it looks as though the then education
secretary thought that teachers would
enjoy not being at school
um Gavin Williamson's never been known
for his wisdom to be honest with you um
and I know he's tacked
um you know look at the u-turns look at
the failures around exams look at the
last minute guidance that was issued to
schools I have huge respects for respect
for our teachers and our school support
stuff up and down the country they make
a huge difference to children's lives
and I think we deserve a government that
gives them the respect and trust that
they deserve something that they um the
messages seemed to tell us was that
labor we know that labor supported masks
in school corridors during the pandemic
but it was a bit you know touch and go
it looked as though Chris witty at the
time didn't think it was you know one
way or the other it didn't actually make
a big difference
labor was always really clear that we
should follow the public health guidance
available at the time and follow the
science
um so lessons
well that's right the matter either way
and I think that's why the inquiry is so
important because we've you know it's
taken a year for the terms of reference
to come forward formal hearings haven't
heard lessons have got to be learned
from the past to inform any future
response to the pandemic but it seems
that
um they decided that masks should be
worn in schools to avoid a fight with
Nicola sturgeon's government I mean
little ones kids wearing masks and all
of the challenges that that created for
them so that we wouldn't get into a
fight with Nicholas sturgeon and labor
supported that
as I said we we always wanted to support
uh decisions that were based on evidence
and based on the public health because
the evidence wasn't there according to
this well I think what we've seen of
course is that the Prime Minister was
more worried about
um keeping the SMP happy than actually
making decisions that that the right for
the classroom and right for parents and
for teachers but shouldn't labor have
pushed harder to try and get the
evidence before backing a decision well
I think we did I think we used every
opportunity available but of course
we're in opposition and it's really
difficult to get information out there
especially during a pandemic but we
certainly were asking all the right
questions at the time and always there
will be lessons to be learned But
ultimately we needed to make sure that
decisions were being made based on the
evidence available to us at the time how
surprised are you to learn now that
actually
the health secretary wanted schools to
be closed and the education secretary
did not want schools to be closed I mean
that was a massive decision for kids at
the time as a result they had online
learning for months and the consequences
of that were significant disruption to
children's lives and the government
have not done anywhere near enough to
recover children from that pandemic and
we had so Kevin Collins who give gave
advice to schools to say this is what
needed to go into recovery and the
government didn't do anywhere near
enough to address those issues but
should labor have pushed harder to find
out the facts the science as you were
saying you're basing your decisions on
the science
I think I do think we did
um you know these things are always
really difficult but clearly what we've
learned is that the government weren't
following the device available to them
so looking back do you think that labor
would have thought twice about
suggesting that kid that supporting the
idea that children should be wearing
masks and corridors
parents
teachers unions wanted to make sure that
the welfare and the well-being of young
people was the priority of this
government so I think they will be
really upset by what they are seeing in
the WhatsApp messages lessons have got
to be learned that you know the
government weren't prepared for the
pandemic the consequences of that was
the chaos that we saw from Gavin
Williamson as as the Secretary of State
at the time but do you think that given
what we know now labor would not have
supported mask wearing in corridors
I think it's really difficult to say
okay
um you know lessons have got to be
learned and what we need to make sure is
that policy is based on the evidence
available at the time but the evidence
available at the time suggested that it
wasn't it was neither here nor there and
yet you supported it
well that was the information we were
given at the time okay talk to me about
stuff that's happening now there were on
the final day of three days of uh
teacher strikes uh today uh we've got
more strikes coming up as well what more
does Jillian Keegan the education
secretary need to do to try to sort this
out well the responsibility for these
strikes and the disruption it's causing
to children's lives and and parents is
the responsibility of this government
and Jillian Keegan has not done enough
in my opinion to sit round in a room
with the teaching unions to to negotiate
a deal labor would have done that months
ago the government were warned months
ago and they were on holiday a half a
half an hour meeting I mean I think
that's tokenistic window dressing
teachers are burnt out they're
overworked they feel really undervalued
by this government the least the
Secretary of State could do is to get
the trade unions in a room lock the door
and negotiate a deal that works for the
country and what should that look like
well it's not for me to say what the
figure should be but what I would want
to see is that the ministers do sit
around the room with the information
available to them and find a deal that
works for teachers it's got to be a fair
deal we've seen that teachers are seeing
their pay reduce in real terms by five
percent uh they are really struggling
with the cost living crisis people are
leaving the profession in their droves
we need a favor
I know
and we also need to see the right
conditions in the classroom again okay
it's good to talk to you actually
joining as much appreciate